this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation and we're talking
about your life i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague rachel cruz and we are
here for you this hour it is a free
phone call triple eight eight two five
five two two five of course with rachel
here we're gonna take all your money
questions i might chime in a little bit
and uh hey we'll talk about your work
your career working on purpose
uh you want that bigger shovel uh we'll
talk about that as well and so we are uh
thrilled to be together this is the
first time that you and i have uh to my
recollection been together in in this
duet so this is very exciting no that's
what you've been claiming but i think
you think you think otherwise yeah you
have no proof i don't have proof so
we're going to go with what i'm going to
go scan the the youtube clips over the
last four years see what happens all
right so uh checking in with you it's
always fun to be together with you in
the studio how's everybody doing yeah
free kiddos great hubs everybody's fine
everyone's great i'll just add this
before we jump in i've experienced
something as a parent
for the first time that i never thought
i would be
oh i'm very excited are you ready yeah
so my six-year-old yeah has done like
gymnastics like she'll do but not an
organized sport she did in 2020 spring
and then it got shut down obviously
because of the pandemic so everything
canceled
so this is the first season fall season
fall 21 that she's on a soccer team
little ymca soccer team how exciting and
she's aggressive kid is she oh boys and
girls uh no just girls just girls oh and
and it's not like where you pumped her
up like amelia you can do this like
run fat you know yeah you just let her
go yeah we were like have fun and melody
will be what do you mean by aggressive
uh oh always just buy the ball kicking
around all this anyway she scored like
three times on saturday after game all
right now hold on we cannot move past
this is very exciting this is what first
time she scores please tell me your
phone your your head was not in your
phone and you saw it
ken coleman i was here at work on
saturday for the financial show
accelerated
i was not here i was not there you
missed it but the phone was on
the phone was on from winston and he
texted me videos the whole thing did he
lose his mind well that's the funny
thing is i turned in so this is what
this is the setup i never thought i
would be that parent that's like
look look at look at my daughter of
course
of course she's amazing look at her look
at her go she's just running
with the ball and just scores anyway so
i'm experiencing that as a parent i've
not yet entered that world and i am a
proud oh yeah
athletic child parents excited
that's it i have a
let me tell you what i think the next
stage of excitement is okay
is
because she had a couple of wins right
three goals hello that's a hat trick all
right
um then you start getting excited like
friday night you go to bed and you go oh
amelia gets to play soccer tomorrow it
gets so excited how i'm feeling right
now 48 hours yeah saturday morning is
like the most exciting thing in your
life i get it anyways good for you
that's what's going on in the crew's
household i've just experienced some new
things yeah um yeah never thought i'd be
that muhammad i am yeah we have three
footballers telling james before the
show we have three football games this
week between my two boys
and so your life is eventually if any
more of your kids play sports your life
becomes an uber driver in between so
there you go it's so crazy all right so
hey uh we'll talk about the busy
parenting we'll talk about budgeting
for all the sports all the things hey
it's wide open
we're here to help you triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
start it off in naples florida with
kristin kristen how can we help
hey how you guys doing we're having a
blast kristen what's up
good all right the show rocks i just
wanted to say that and i am i explain
all the principles from the show to my
students almost daily because i teach oh
good for you what what grade do you
teach
high school great
yeah so yeah that's great thanks for uh
putting it out there um
all right so my question is i am
currently eligible for the public
student loan forgiveness for my student
loans that i accumulated over the years
um and it's at 72 because of interest
has been occurring since 2015.
um
and i'm wondering because they said that
i i'll have them paid off by 2028
and i'm only making the minimum payment
from because i'm on the you know
repayment plan where it's income driven
based
and i'm just wondering if that's the
route i should take or should i just try
to attack them because i have no other
debt besides that that's it
how much student loan debt kristin is it
in total uh 72 000 oh you said that 72
yep
yep
so the way
my philosophy always with this is
usually with these forgiveness programs
are you talking on like the national
level are you in a specific program
with your teaching
with your teaching that you're part of
something because there are organic
organizations out there that are helping
with student loan forgiveness but you
have to be in a certain job in a certain
system for a certain number of years is
that the program you're talking about or
more on like a national level like
biden's gonna forgive your student loans
no because i you have to be at work in a
title one school district which i do and
i teach science so i'm in it i'm in that
program and they said hey you'll they'll
be paid off by 2028 as long as you make
120 qualifying payments for 10 years yes
so okay so this is how i i would go
about it because of the length of time
and because these promises have this has
been
you know these things have come up
multiple times over the past two decades
and sometimes it works sometimes it's
fulfilled sometimes it's not and so
there's all these tiny little
uh
details in your story and in your
employment all of that that what it ends
up being is that you're basically
putting
your fate of being debt free in someone
else's hands
so my philosophy with it is attack it
kristin what you can do and what you can
pay down
working to pay it off because you're
going to be able to pay it off faster
than 2028 and i don't
have the hope and the trust honestly
that it it's 100 gonna go through
because the last thing i want you to do
is just be paying the minimum payments
and you get to 2028
and something is screwed up or something
changed or your life changed and you're
no longer teaching i mean there's so
much risk around that idea so if i were
you kristin i would buckle down and pay
it off even though it's a lot and i know
it seems overwhelming especially on a
teacher's salary
but what you can do to put the control
back in your hands is what i would push
for kristin which way were you leaning
when you called in
um waiting but i don't i like paying
everything else because i have zero debt
besides my student loans so i was like
well
you know i could attack these you know i
can put a lot towards it but then i'm
like wait i have forgiveness of my
occupation but
yeah you never know what's going to
happen in the future yeah if you if you
go at it with everything you've got
because you know our program you teach
it you believe in it how quickly you
think you can pay it off
[Music]
oh
come on i'm thinking
three maybe three years yeah yeah and i
think i think rachel's absolutely right
you're gonna you're gonna do it in that
amount of time if not sooner because of
your actual drive and once you taste
some momentum on this i think it's going
to be an awesome awesome push for you
and there is no guarantee
these things are not guaranteed and i'd
hate for you to wait
seven years
and then be at the same place you are
now versus knock this thing out you took
the loan
you took the loan out
you should pay it back now that's my
opinion i'm not gonna rant on that but
if you take a loan out y'all not wait
around for uncle sam or somebody else to
forgive what you already signed up for
pay it off you'll do it faster than you
could possibly imagine if you really get
after it and you're going to feel so
much better about it and then you have a
story to tell all those students that
you have tremendous influence over hey
han thank you so much excuse me kristen
thank you so much for sharing your story
and thank you for calling the show she
is rachel cruz i'm ken coleman we're
here for you don't move coming right
back after the break
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to feartalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
the ramsey show continues welcome back
america i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague rachel cruz and we are here
together to take your questions about
your life your money
your work purpose relationships we'll
just talk about it all we love
having a conversation with you and
that's what this show is all about
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so do you
really love the work you do is it
fulfilling for you
for example i come to work because i
still get fired up about the work i do
and if you're not fired up you might be
stuck in the wrong job or wrong career
not using your talents we've taken my
proven plan that has helped thousands
and we've launched a power pack bundle
that combines my new book from paycheck
to purpose and the new get clear career
assessment the team here has packaged it
uh together into the ultimate career
bundle and it's a steal for only thirty
dollars i didn't even approve that
rachel we're practically giving away the
assessment that's a thirty dollar
assessment they're giving away for 10
bucks
with the book so
jump on this it's going to help you get
clear on your talent what you do best
your passion work you love and your
mission results that you want to
contribute to the world
through your work it's going to give you
a list of many professional options that
will be in your sweet spot and the book
gives you the proven step-by-step plan
to get you up the mountain to that
professional pinnacle you can pick
between the get hired bonus pack and get
promoted bonus pack depending on where
you are in your journey and that's free
over a hundred dollars of value
for just thirty dollars so
go to the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
that's ramseysolutions.com and order the
ultimate career bundle today for only
thirty dollars triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
let's go to portland oregon next hannah
joins us there hannah how can we help
hi guys um thank you for having me i
wanted to ask um i have been following
dave ramsey since the beginning of this
year and i'm on babysit number three hey
my question was
my question was how
what is maybe the best way to get into
the dating scene and follow dave
ramsey's plan at the same time like how
do you talk to people
if you're interested in them about being
debt-free
and finding the right partner
wow that's a great question hannah boy i
have thoughts on this one wow
i have some vlogs
but this is what's going to spring
ladies first and what i like is hannah's
going to get both sides of the
perspective here ladies first oh i'm
ready um
so hannah i don't feel like it needs to
be a conversation
right off the bat by any means
uh i think as you start dating and if
it's like if it's one person
consistently you're going to pick up
naturally
their spending habits probably how they
talk about stuff i mean money is such an
integral part of life so it's it's
naturally going to come up
in conversation and again even just you
being aware of
of how they're handling their money and
so as the as it gets more serious though
in a relationship and you know
okay this is probably this is heading
towards marriage like i'm feeling it
then that's when conversations about
life in general i feel like get more
serious and a little bit more tangible
and that's everything from kids
money
uh if if you have a spiritual walk right
a faith story that that comes into play
i mean a lot of these things
naturally are going to come up while
you're dating but i think as it gets
serious that's when you start to turn to
say okay how much are we on the same
page um because i i would not advise nor
can maybe you would that you like ask
for their
you know tax returns on like the first
how much are you investing in your 401k
you know those things are not natural
you know questions the beginning of a
relationship um have you had experience
hannah i'm just curious of
of dating and you're thinking though in
the back of your mind you're scared to
get into a relationship where you're
unsure what what what is the what's
what's the reason behind your question
well because i got divorced when i was
21 years old i just
so there's that part of me that i hear
about these couples on here that's
growing and getting out of debt and
you know i want to be
close to that partner um whoever they
are but i just want to make sure that we
are because you know i they talked about
it all the time money's you know one of
the biggest issues yep um
and that's my fear absolutely i just
want to find that right person now
hannah
i'm 25. okay so awesome couple i'm just
going to give you i'm going to give you
the dude perspective and and then i'm
going to give you just kind of this
financial peace perspective on on moving
forward
uh
so you don't want to talk about this
early on okay you might as if you're
going to talk about debt and budgets and
what do you think about money on a first
date you might as well take a catalog of
your cats with you i mean it's just a
horrible idea
don't do it here let's here's how a dude
thinks about dating all right first
thing they want to connect
second they got to figure out if they
like you third if they like you then we
hope they start to dig you all right so
that's next level from like they dig you
they want to spend more time then they
commit and then finally love
so this i'm just breaking i just wrote
down connect like
hannah you need to know right in front
of coleman
i got it because yeah you need to know
this this is how dudes think and so
when we get to commit that's four so let
me review for all the single ladies
connect the dude's got to connect with
him then they got you got to get him to
like you
then you want him to dig you and then
you want to commit
when we get to commit this is level four
james i just made up this this
unbelievable knowledge right here on the
spot you're such a preacher's kid what's
that such a preacher's kid well it's
just true i just laid it out right here
when we get to level four commit then we
start talking about
hey what are your views on money see how
i'm spinning this from a little bit of
fun to seriously now we start going hey
how did your parents handle money when
you grow up maybe you buy rachel cruz's
book
maybe you do and
you say i read this book know yourself
know your money and you talk about
where's it and how you see money here's
another thought hannah and then we'll
let you know i didn't get to finish oh
i'm so sorry so that's the last piece if
you find out that he's on opposite
worlds of partying like he's totally
opposite of you on money now you can
start to get nervous and go hey here's
how i see money this could be a major
divide are you and if we see if he's
willing to then
make some changes there you go go ahead
i was trying to i was trying to plug
your classrooms and all the things
because it's wonderful it actually is a
wonderful way to talk about money well
that's all i was going to say is a lot
of these conversations
could be in your unproven uh five-step
plan number three oh right
that a part of oh you're moving it up
what okay but i'm being honest as you're
in a relationship and this could be a
romantic relationship this could be even
just a friendship but when you start to
really
understand people and know them on a
deeper level
and what makes them who they are
those conversations is what
it's gonna make you know
them dig you slash you dig them yeah and
part of that is hey here's like how i
see the world and here's how i view
things and here's like oh there's a
family over there with kids let's judge
them and figure out how i would do
different you know in parenting style
like like understanding someone on a on
a depth level i would say the way money
is handled the way you view money how it
acts in your life
is possibly in level three it's i'm okay
with that because i just made it up i'm
willing to move her but but i think we
don't want to do it in the connect and
the likes yeah so hannah that's that's
your answer
no it was wonderful that was a circle
but i don't know that anybody's ever
gotten that depth of advice on dating
and money talk at the same time that was
wonderful it's really really good hannah
but i think it's awesome and also hannah
your question sorry i'm gonna keep going
because we have two we have one more
minute we can't take another caller in
one minute okay is that it's out of her
fear yeah that's what she said she's
terrified how do i bring it up well and
she doesn't want to get with a guy
exactly exactly and so
fear i don't think is the best motivator
in life i think it's a great motivator
at times i agree with you but let that
fear understand why why is that your
fear hannah is it because you want to
feel
provided you want to feel connected like
understanding that why the fear drives
you
that's going to help also to unpack and
try to kind of pinpoint who you want you
can call you can call me dr joan delaney
yeah i like that i like that but let me
you know what what's what else is is
important i think to point out get your
quick perspective
you don't want to go into it feeling
like you got to find the guy who agrees
with you lockstep on everything
certainly not money sure they may not
have any education they may not have the
knowledge that she has she's been
working baby steps since the beginning
of the year she's already baby step
three so give folks some grace be
patient with them hey they might believe
in the baby steps but if they don't know
it don't discount them because he's got
credit card debt there you go all right
hey uh we're taking your questions about
life money work the whole nine yards she
is rachel cruz i'm ken coleman and this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined in studio by my colleague my
co-host today rachel cruz and we are
taking your phone calls the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go back to the
phones wassaw i think is how we say that
wisconsin is where we go and ashley is
there ashley how can we help hi um my
husband and i are both 23
um we're on baby step three and
i make forty thousand dollars a year i'm
working as a subcontractor for the post
flow service and then my husband has a
couple different jobs and he makes about
twenty thousand a year and i'm just
wondering um i did a farm as funny ship
a couple years
years ago and my family has a farm
and i really want to be doing that with
my life
and i don't hate the job i have now but
it just gets very monotonous you know
how to justify
taking a pay cut um to do what i want to
do okay so tell me how big of a pay cut
it would be you're making 40k now what
would you make if you went to work for
something you've identified
i think prior to this call on a farm
well i do work for my parents um i do
kind of subcontractor stuff for them
so i raise cattle and chickens for them
every year and
i make about eight thousand dollars
right now on the side
um and it can be expanded some i just
don't know how much and i make 180 a day
flat rate doing
the postal service work so i just feel
guilty every time i take more time to
invest in the farm because i know i can
be making you know 180 if i was just at
work and i can make so much more being
there even though it's not what i want
to do well first of all
you don't need to feel guilty you're not
doing anything wrong
okay be one thing if you were uh being
paid a salary and you were staying home
watching soap operas i might be fine
with some guilt about that but you're
not doing anything wrong here so let's
remove the guilt
um i got a couple things unpack here so
the eight thousand you're making for
your mom and dad on the farm if i heard
that correctly uh is that included in
your forty thousand total
um no it's not that the forty thousand
is from the postal
so you're making 48 000.
okay and so
okay great how about why is your husband
only making 20 000 if i heard you
correctly you broke up some with two
jobs what's he doing
um
he works for a tree service in the
summer that he makes
um about 11 000 at but it's seasonal um
we have a lot of snow here in the winter
so they can't do work from november
until april um and then we just oh we
just start opening a butcher shop on
farm this fall and so
he um he's starting that but but it's
starting out slow so we're trying not to
go into debt for it and so
it's not um we don't have a bunch of
employees or anything but he's not
making all right as much yet how long
before you're through baby step three
and how much do you have to save to get
there
um i'm hoping to save about 7 500 more
and we should be done by about january
okay
so couple things here um
i'm assuming your hubs is on board with
you and your passion to work on a farm
correct the family farm or any farm
right
yes okay so i think you have to answer
this question and you can't answer it
right now i don't think because you
haven't done the research the only
context you have is you're making eight
thousand dollars working for your mom
and dad i think that's awesome but you
need to go do some homework um in your
area and go okay what job positions are
out there they don't even have to be
open we just want to do research that
will pay forty thousand dollars let's
just start there okay uh 40 let's call
it 40 to 50 since you're really at 48.
so let's look at what jobs in our area
uh on farms pay 40 to 50 000 we got to
get really knowledgeable on that so we
know what the target is because that
becomes a target now again they may not
be open but that's okay because now we
have a target so that's your first
homework assignment i want you to be
able to see what's possible secondly i
think this is a
steak dinner with hubs and you say you
called in the show and this guy named
kenny probably doesn't know who i am and
he doesn't care and i don't care either
because i could be the bad guy here and
i think you just say look he he thinks
that we've got to step our game up uh in
totality and so uh maybe the butcher
shop maybe not the best time to do that
uh or if we're gonna do the butcher shop
and go for it yes we're gonna cash flow
it but it is a true side hustle so maybe
it becomes like your farm job for mom
and dad right now and he's no longer
doing the seasonal tree job he's going
out there and he's getting himself a job
making anywhere from 15 to 25 excuse me
dollars an hour and ashley i know this
is possible because we are in the
hottest job economy in the history of
the united states and you just go down
there and do the math with him on a
calculator what 15 an hour pays and if
he can increase his income and we treat
the butcher shop as a side hustle so any
money coming out of that is gravy and
you transition into the farm work i
think that's the path rachel any
thoughts on that i think that's a
marital discussion ago we collectively
got to work on the dream together and
i'd like to see her move from the postal
office pretty soon into a farm job yeah
absolutely and actually too i'm like
from the numbers perspective
you know understanding okay what what
level of lifestyle
are we
wanting or okay living at because there
is a choice there right that you can
work
40 hours a week he could go do exactly
what ken said and you guys you i mean
who knows you could be making a hundred
grand a year double he could be making
forty thousand yeah so i'm like and if
you you know stuck it out and you guys
did something on the side the butcher
thing took off i mean like there's a
level where you're like yeah you can
make a hundred grand a year which is
awesome but if that takes away and
that's not what you value you you would
be okay
at 60 at 60
doing something you love it's those kind
of conversations it it it doesn't always
have to be this or that no ideally
you're doing what you love and you guys
are just killing it financially you're
able to to win and change your family
tree and be generous and all of that but
sometimes it is that question of okay do
i take the pay cut to do something i
love and is that is the lifestyle change
gonna be okay and it's worth it right so
ashley i remember we had some friends
two lawyers worked their butts off and
made a lot of money but they you know
kids were in daycare i mean it was it
was you know 50 hour a week job for each
of them but they made a lot of money and
they for them it was like yeah we're
making this money because so now we're
able to do amazing stuff with our kids
they took two weeks off every summer and
traveled they were able to do things and
that's what they valued i also had
friends and he was a teacher she was a
stay-at-home mom that's right they may
not you know they they lived with four
kids yeah and they're tight budget but
they're like you know what we would
rather sacrifice lifestyle to do what he
loves and to do it you know what i'm
saying i don't know ken is that
congruent with your teacher no i think
you're spot on ashley and so so that's
really that's really one answer to your
first question i want you to see what's
out there i think there's probably
better options than you think out there
i don't want you to assume you're going
to take a pay cut to go do what you love
but rachel is also making a very good
point that hey let's say that you find a
great job on a farm that pays you 32
then you adjust your lifestyle and again
hubs wants to do the butcher shop that's
clearly a passion play is that right he
that's his dream to have the butcher
shop yeah and we have it built now so
it's just a matter of right starting but
here's the deal but here's the deal on
that
it's okay for that to grow slow all
right so if he's got a day job it for a
year or two while the dream job is
growing on the side that's fine so i
think you guys are in great position i
want you to walk out of here going huh i
don't necessarily have to take a big pay
cut let's find out what's out there and
then rachel's right if you guys make an
adjustment and your collective income
doubles which i think it can for a
season until hubs gets the butcher shop
going then you guys are in fantastic
position before you know it you're out
of baby step three you're saving in baby
step four fifteen percent and now we're
able to invest for baby step five when
they get the whole nine yards yeah and
before you know it you're living the
dream and by the way this is why i wrote
the book from paycheck to purpose rachel
you can make income the income you want
and the impact that you want and and
that's where she'll be yeah they're
doing they're 23. 23. so this is an
amazing questions you're asking ashley
because if you can if you guys can nail
this and at least be on the path the
answer doesn't have to be next month it
doesn't have to be in the next two
months but you guys are working towards
a life a full life from lifestyle career
finance all of that that is congruent
together
this young it's a beautiful thing it is
that can happen
i i love it i love to hear that story
both of them having their dream yeah and
by the way very congruent yes she wants
to be around livestock and agriculture
he wants to run a butcher shop that's
really cool send us the info the butcher
shop thinking about we're thinking about
going in for a cow you know you are yeah
once i haven't talked about it dairy cow
uh yeah but for all the meat
well yeah it's a dairy cows is that
interesting i don't know ashley ashley
we need to have a phone call and teach
me all the things we've got ashley on
hold let's keep her on hold so she can
give rachel an agricultural lesson
during
the commercial break oh my goodness
great work though great workout well so
i want a couple steaks out of that cap i
know so
let
give us a price point james i'm what
they call a city slicker and even i know
that dairy cow doesn't give you meat i'm
just going to leave that there sharon
ramsey would be so disappointed to me
right now oh my gosh that's why we love
her she's rachel cruz i'm ken coleman
and this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show we're thrilled
to have you with us i'm ken coleman
joined by by my colleague rachel cruz
and we're taking your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five your money calls your life calls
work
getting that bigger shovel doing work
you love and crossing over into
something where you make income and
impact uh we even took a call about
how to date
and move through the baby steps so i
mean we're just taking your life calls
so we love it and i'm a i'm a rancher
apparently i know a lot i know a lot
about farming yeah it's very exciting
it's very exciting rachel cruz buys a
cow that's coming to her youtube channel
so stay tuned for that in the days ahead
but now we go to amy who joins us in
denver colorado amy how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call
i'm looking i think for some outside
guidance
first i have to say i'm blessed for the
life i have i'm grateful
um i'm restless though and i'm
discontented with it and
i think my question is ultimately how do
i advocate for myself or sell myself
or get a seat at the table
i left three years ago i left a a
private sector job management managing
people managing operations
six figure jobs lots of hours pretty
miserable
to i just had an opportunity to leave it
and i wanted i know i needed to be part
of
community that's the only thing i come
up with i want to be more involved with
community
i took a job you know cut my salary in
half and i took a job and it's great i
love working 40 hours
it's really nice um
you know but i'm not stimulated i'm not
challenged i'm it's it's nothing out of
it and uh and i
kind of conceded okay if i want to get
back into challenging that means i'd
have to manage people which i'm not
quite sure i'm the right person for
uh i've taken all kinds of steps to
you know professionally network and do
presentations and do stuff outside of my
comfort zone um
and i'm in a different sector and so i'm
you know obviously i'm young in the
sector and i'm looked at as pretty much
zero experience
so
amy so are you telling me you have no
idea you have no direction there's not
something that you'd want to try
professionally if lack of experience
lack of connections lack of fear lack of
doubt if i could just wipe it away
you're telling me you have no idea you
haven't wondered about a type of work
oh no i have that's what i want to hear
i want to hear what would you do
tomorrow this is a simple question and i
need you to suspend your brain here this
is a heart only answer what would you
try tomorrow you'd have to commit the
rest of your work life to it but you'd
try it if you knew you couldn't fail
what work would you do
it's it's kind of it's a motivational
thing coaching coaching who
you know the answer don't even hey i saw
what just happened by the way i do this
every day on the ken coleman show so now
you're trapped all right and this is a
good thing
you know the answer who do you want to
coach
it's women and i laugh because uh it's
just in the last five years women have
become a part of my life and i i've
always been around men so it's just
funny okay so who so i understand you
want to coach women but what challenge
do they have that you want to help them
solve
to overcome obstacles that they can't do
it
can't do what
well there's different things like i
i've done some um
some physical fitness type stuff and
i've seen women come in it's their first
time and they're not made through and i
run next to them and do push-ups with
them
i just took a bunch of ladies out on a
mud run who's never done it before um
i've consulted with fundraisers who
don't know how to fundraise and i'm not
a fundraiser right right
you know what you are amy you're you you
personally are a go-getter and i think
if we were to just pick one word and i
don't want you to after this phone call
lock into this word and make it your
personal brand but i want you to just
open your mind to this
um but i think you are a coach
and when you say you want to coach it's
because i think you are a coach like i
think that's just who you are you kind
of just bounce into people and when you
see them down or a little bit different
you know and they're not where they're
supposed to be you can see they don't
have their spark and you want to figure
out why and then help them get their
spark is that a fair
close analysis
yeah okay so here's the deal for today
let's just say you want to be a
performance coach i think you've got to
do some research on this and we got to
figure out how we transition i think
that's the biggest scariest part but you
could be a life coach i don't really
care what you label it but i think you
got to look at where am i going to
specialize
excuse me where am i going to specialize
now you may offer a suite of things
maybe you offer some financial coaching
and some nutritional exercise fitness
coaching maybe it's more in the career
space i don't know but that's your
homework assignment you got to go okay
what are the one of the biggest or
what's the list of of challenges your
word obstacles that women face that you
get the most juice
when you think about helping those women
climb that obstacle therein lies your
answer now we've got this day job
and so we've got to look at the
financial piece how we make the
transition so once you know what you
want to do you ask this in fact i'm
going to give you four qualifying
questions you got something to write
with
i'm ready great first thing is once we
figure out the type of coaching we want
to do we have to ask what do i need to
learn
okay this is the education question does
not mean a four year degree necessarily
in fact in this case it's not it's some
certification is what we're looking at
so that's the education question what i
need to learn second question is what do
i need to do what's the experience
question what experience am i gonna need
to do to get to where i start getting
some people some women in and i coach
them leads to the third question what's
that gonna cost me okay that's the
financial question what's gonna cost to
get qualified how am i gonna have to
sacrifice some of my work time
you know that's what we're looking for
what's the financial cost
that's the economic question and the
fourth one is the expectation question
how long is this gonna take
now
when you get the answers to those four
questions amy guess what you've got a
plan
and you're gonna walk into it you're not
gonna jump you're not gonna leap and
you're not gonna put your day job at
risk so this is again most likely a side
hustle unless in denver you know fairly
good sized metropolitan area unless
there's some type of position like this
at a corporation that wants a
performance coach and you can help women
there you know you just got to look
everywhere
but this is this is the direction you
got to look and i think if you do it
you're going to find it
okay got it
yes thank you you bet thanks for the
call you know it's interesting rachel
when when
i get these calls of course every day on
the ken coleman show but
when someone tells me i just don't know
i just don't know i've never had
somebody when you dig and you push they
go they don't know what they're not what
they what they really mean is i'm not
sure
yeah there's a difference between i
don't know what i want to do or i have
no idea i'm completely clueless ken
and i don't know how to get there the
first one's not true the second one it's
very understandable how do i get there
there's fear there's doubt this is a
woman who's been very successful made
really good money six figures and just
walked away because she was in a
leadership position and i admire her she
went i don't want to lead people yeah
it probably drains her
that and working 80 hours a week too
she's like man you know i want a
different yeah i want a different scope
of life yeah and i think it's amazing
i'm like and and more
of this i could be wrong maybe it's just
my stage of life but amy what she
describes though
of people going out
wanting to do something that fulfills
them but even in that space of just
helping people
like seeing i see that more and more and
more and more people are willing to pay
someone to help them with that where i
feel like
maybe 30 40 years ago it was like well
just pull your you know i think you're
absolutely right just coaching
push through but the coaching aspect is
beautiful because i think people are
willing to learn and they're asking
questions and they want help and when
amy someone like her has
the answers and some of this experience
that she's learned she's like i can plug
in like i can help and that's that's
where i think the beauty is and and what
you do too ken is helping people find
that like what does that look like to be
able to help people and you're motivated
in it and yeah you're killing it
financially unique role you know all of
us have it
whether it's a public role or a private
role whether it's i just like
fixing machines and you're in your happy
place when you're left alone to work and
fix a problem that's connected to an
engine or whatever and then there's the
person who wants to create art
you know what i mean and they and
they're kind of off in their own world
and they're creating or writers um or
engineers or teachers
what it comes down to again is
what you heard from amy was
she's encountered some women there's
been some personal experiences that have
driven this purpose yeah she's kind of
going
i i've always had direction
and i don't like when i see my sisters
out here we don't have direction or
don't think they can do it i don't think
they can do it
and she's the coach yeah she's just the
general coach so really good stuff amy
you're very inspiring thank you so much
for calling us you're going to do great
things to help women in the denver area
so go with everything you got hey i want
to thank my colleague rachel cruz always
fun i want to thank our producer james
childs our associate producer and call
screener jenna sears but mostly you
america this is your show this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsay
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
money your relationships we'll talk
about your work and purpose i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague rachel
cruz
we are here for you this hour it is a
free phone call triple eight eight two
five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's get it started
this hour in austin texas where robbie
joins us robbie how can we help
uh hello thanks for taking my call i
just want to give you a quick question
uh we are on baby step two we have our
starter emergency fund saved
i'm trying to figure out whether i
should finish school
or pay off all of our debt and our
student loans
our gross income is about 80 000 a year
and we have 99 000 in debt
without any raises i've estimated it to
be paid off in like 3.9 years
but i'm trying to get a better idea of
what i should do just because you know
i've seen the debts get free screens and
that's really what i want more than i
want you know the degree right how much
do you have left in your degree
uh i've got two and a half years but the
the thing about it is i've got about 50
000 in student loans and i'm estimating
at least another
30 to 40 000
in student loans to finish you know for
to finish yeah okay so
and what's what's the degree and robby
are you doing it to advance and career
um
it would be a bachelor's of science in
psychology
what are you doing now for work
uh right now i'm a phlebotomist at a
blood bank here in austin texas what do
you what did you go for the degree for
did you want to move into that field
um you know i'd like to move into
psychology as a counselor
but then also i'm going to need a
master's which is you know even more uh
even more money for school yeah um
couple things have you done your
homework on other schools where you can
get the degree to see if you can save
just on tuition
i've looked into two different schools
one in arizona and the other one was
southern new hampshire
and i think there's maybe a difference
of three thousand four thousand dollars
uh per semester yeah it's an expensive
degree
okay so um is your wife working as well
yes we both work what's your combined
income
uh combined income our gross is just
over 80 000. okay so that was the 80 000
number and you got 3.9 years if we stay
at uh the 80 000.
uh yeah to pay off just over 99 000
yeah um
because you've got two years left
uh on this program and because you can't
cashflow your way through it yeah i'm
pressing pause
because okay counseling is still going
to be there the dream job is still going
to be there and that's what you got to
hold on to and i love that you led with
the question because i think you've been
considering that is that the way you
were leaning before the call
yeah i mean i was leaning
into hopefully paying this off because i
just think it i mean it's just going to
be so freeing to not have that and yes
and get a degree how old are you robbie
uh i am 38. okay awesome yeah
yeah there
there's a couple dynamics there that i
think are important because
i think pressing pause is the wisest
thing right now and
paying off this debt because what can
happen even in four years
to even just the education market and
what can open up of how to in your in
those
classes hopefully they don't expire or
you're able to to still have those
credits because you've taken those
courses
is possibly options to plug in somewhere
else like ken was saying in four years
but also robby that
in four years with no debts and then
going to school on the side
while working and then you're going to
want to launch into this you know maybe
be part of a counseling practice start
your own whatever that looks like it's
almost like launching into this new
thing and when you launch into a new
thing with no risk aka having no debts
that you're having to pay
um
it gives that transition even more peace
even more piece of being able to do it
now
with the caveat that if you can find
something to go cheaper like ken was
saying and you're looking and there's
ways to go on the side and get that
while you're still making the 80 grand
and you're still able to pay it off um
in that four years you know if you're
able to do both still simultaneously
that could be an option because i
understand the feeling of
if you feel drawn and called to
something you know i hate that money
becomes the blocker but in this case
it has a little bit robby because of the
financial hole that you guys are in with
this almost 100k what is the uh if 50
000 of student loans what's the other 40
oh we're normal we got a little bit of
everything
cars credit cards
loans
um
yeah okay what are your what are your
cars worth and what do you owe on them
uh
i think we're we're negative on those i
think one car we owe 19 and the other
one 15.
yeah well let me tell you this
you can make up ground really quick if
you're willing to drive something really
really cheap and and i've got a 15 year
old boy who's going to be 16 in november
so rachel i've been all over our uh used
car sites yeah
and you'd be surprised how decent of a
car you can get for five thousand i was
going to say you could get 25 grand
robbie just by selling the cars 5 000
yeah hustling to get those cars right
side up right and then selling them and
driving something really really cheap
you're going to make up a lot of ground
that's a tremendous amount of time and
i'm going to challenge the four years
even just hearing you talk i'm like you
guys like you said you've been normal
and this is not to shame you
but you guys got to stop but you kind of
have to get to a point where you said
we're done we're done and we're cutting
everything out of our lives we're
cutting the expenses all this stuff
we've just been floating through buying
the cars we want charging stuff on
credit cards like like it's gotta
tighten up so much and your life is
gonna drastically look different and i
think if you guys commit to this change
wholeheartedly with the idea of getting
a degree in psychology to be a counselor
as a motivator i bet you guys can do
this way less than four years i think
you can i think you guys have just been
kind of mosing around which again that's
not to shame you that is normal like you
said
but man if you guys if you guys went
extreme and you did that you sold the
cars i mean that's 25 000 extra with two
5 000 cars and paid for car sit in the
driveway i mean if you if you do some
stuff
to really shake up what you guys have
been doing it's going to be
uncomfortable it's not going to be it's
not going to be easy
but you guys had i'm like you can you
can clean this up and and by 43 years
old you could be living a totally
different life in a different career in
a different place financially yeah robby
you've got two big motivators right now
rachel's right this is this is like
we're going nuclear here we're pressing
the red emergency button and it's all in
on everything cutting your expenses
drastically selling everything working
an extra job because you're going to
pause for right now maybe six months on
the school i agree with rachel i think
if you get a lot of stuff paid off
quickly you could cash flow a class here
and there while still going through the
debt snowball you have that ability but
i want you to think about two things
here one being debt free
and and two having a debt-free practice
not just debt free personally but then
today i'm gonna counsel people i'm gonna
love on the people that i have a heart
for and the reason you got into
counseling you know what it is but you
better keep that really close because
the next couple years are going to be
intense and they're going to be really
hard but you think about the people that
you want to sit knee to knee with
eyeball to eyeball
and help them with breakthrough in their
life that's your why
and it's worth it but it's going to be
hard but the degree
it'll be there and so will the dream job
thank you robbie for the call you got
this but today's the day you got to get
serious got to make the change and it's
always worth it all right folks don't
move more ramsey show coming up right
around the corner
[Music]
let's go
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
rachel cruz the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five so question for you folks
how many times in the past year have you
heard someone say i just wish things
would get back to normal
but what was normal like for you were
you worried about money
was that your normal well you shouldn't
have to go back to that and there's
so much better ahead for you
but to get the life you want you got to
have a game plan so join us for game
plan live this is our free live stream
on september the 28th dave ramsey
christy wright and george campbell will
be laying out the clear plan to make all
of your money goals happen you can have
the abundant balanced debt-free life you
want and it all starts at game plan live
if you want to register for this live
stream text game plan to
33789 that's game plan all one word text
game plan to three three
seven eight
nine all right let's go to binghamton
new york dominico is there dominico how
can we help
hey
hey my fiancee turned me to you guys
just this week on my 23rd birthday oh
wow
happy birthday
check out these crazy people on
this podcast
you don't sound terribly excited about
it do you hate us you can be honest
no i've actually been listening to you
guys very religiously all week listening
to you guys at work everything i just
bought dave's book yesterday total money
makeover i've been reading it every
night
amazing but my fiance and i were talking
last night because we're going over our
bills for the rest of the month and
she got she told me to call and get your
guys opinion because we can't figure out
what to do
um
my car
i
have i have a car payment sadly
um
and my loan is like fifteen thousand
seven hundred sixty two dollars
and i pay 283 25 a month but it's only
kelly blue book valued at seven thousand
nine hundred seventy two dollars yeah
so i'm trying for
we were trying to figure out would be
better just for me to
get rid of the car or
keep it or
what to do because we're getting behind
on bills and everything and we're just
trying to get stuff figured out because
we moved into our first apartment
together
just back in june okay
okay how much do you make a year
um
i want to say roughly maybe about
forty thousand forty okay and what other
debt do you have besides the car
just you know your fiance just you
um my credit cards
which i got
a
credit card for
for my car to fix it which that's um
that i
use just for an oil change um i've had a
car through walmart and i got a so how
much is how much how much total do you
think is in credit card debt
uh about a thousand about a thousand
okay and that's all you have no student
loans yeah
and your student loans awesome okay
so
i think for you i mean kind of our rule
of thumb is if you can't pay off the car
in 18 months
it needs to go
12 to 18 months so if you don't think
you can pay it off in a year that you
can just
you know work you're you know working an
extra job selling stuff doing whatever
you can to throw money at this car
payment well first the credit card i
want you to get rid of that thousand
dollar credit card cut out the credit
cards when we get off the phone if you
haven't already like get rid of those
get a thousand dollars saved up thousand
dollars to your car so you're you have
about two thousand dollars
to get this ball rolling to get your
emergency fund and then to start
attacking this car
um
so if you can't pay it off uh in 12 to
18 months then yeah my my advice would
be to sell it and you'll take you'll
have to take a loan for the difference
um because you won't be able to get as
much you know
you're not able to sell the car and then
make some money off of it obviously
because it's gone down in value so much
but to take that loan
um which will be obviously less than
that i mean you'll have eight thousand
dollars
left on that car loan and that's what
you could attack instead of the fifteen
thousand if that's what if that's what
you choose unless you just decide to
buckle down
and
attack
the car payments and the car the car
loan
uh in the next year
how much are you making dominica
40. i'm ex i make 16 an hour but my
yearly income is like around 45. and and
what is that job what are you doing
um i work at a fabrication shop yeah
where would you go
to make extra money if you wanted to
make i mean if you really went hard you
you don't have kids yes or no
no no kids so it's just you two and this
is your debt not
uh you know the two of you is debt so
what would you do could you pick up some
more fabricating work you know around
cars and stuff make some really nice
money per hour if you added another 15
to 30 hours a week
yeah like i've already got a second job
lined up i'm gonna be working like
friday saturday nights at a haunted
attraction for the halloween season how
much is that going to pay you
uh
about like 250 a weekend because i'm
only working two days a weekend yeah
well good for you but i would really
look at your other options i mean can
you pick up some extra work you know
messing around on cars or whatever just
to maximize
uh your income right now because this
you could knock this stuff out easily
in nine nine months twelve months if you
really just worked like a maniac this is
not that much money
yeah like i've been
cutting applications out for second jobs
anywhere i've been putting applications
at gas stations and all yeah but hold on
a second domenico listen listen man
you're worth way more than that
don't put apple cases in to a gas
station you're you're a skilled
tradesman
i mean think about how many people you
know in the car game am i right or am i
wrong am i missing something
yeah i'm
yeah i'm completely not looking at the
bigger picture
all right but believe me you're saying
it i'm not looking at it no you're not
dude you're a skilled tradesman i'd be
looking for that kind of work where you
can be making 18 an hour 25 an hour
where the the time is really paying off
not standing there holding a rope and
letting a bunch of idiot teenagers walk
through a haunted house it's just not a
good use of your time we got to get
serious you have a real skill
yeah yeah what do you think what do you
think about this do you agree with me
i'm okay to be wrong yeah
no i i'm agreeing with you i just i'm
just speechless because i've
never really thought about it like that
i've always
grown up with you get what you can get
and don't feel fit but now that you're
saying it now it's like
well i actually agree with that i agree
but listen get what you can get and the
haunted house ain't get what you can get
that's just get whatever's there
go out there and get some skilled trades
work that you're already qualified for
and you've got all kinds of connections
you're in that game already you're a
fabricator that is a premium physical
trade man uh we're talking about can i
make 500 700 over a weekend let's set
our sites a little bit bigger let's get
a third job because again we're looking
at uh sixteen thousand seven hundred
sixty dollars uh that you've gotta pay
off and i know you're brand new to this
and i'm so glad you called but i'm gonna
tell you something man if you start
seeing yourself as a money-making
machine
you'll go out and do that and we won't
settle for the haunted house thing so
here's a little challenge domenico i
want you to go find some other work and
then call the haunted house people up
and say hey i'm sorry i got something
better
you got a few weeks haunted house people
to fill my spot i'm about to make three
times on what i was going to make i love
that ken well done deuces i'm out of
here i'm not doing that but to give
people the
you know and again not that working at a
haunted house or gas station there's
nothing wrong with it no nothing wrong
with that but the fact that you have the
skill and to be able to value yourself
yeah even more in the marketplace and
again
you're you've been in this for four days
right just this week so there there is a
level of all this that you're learning
so much so i just want to applaud you on
that of just learning and saying hey
what i'm doing i want to do something
different and now your mind you're
starting to grow in that your mind is
being expanded and so this challenge ken
has given you is wonderful so well done
ken i love i love hearing that and
hearing you demonica be like man okay
yeah i can do this because you can yes
you do that dominica this is for your
future bride your babies i mean you got
the chance to wipe this debt absolutely
free in nine months 12 months at the
most and your future is the best
that you could possibly imagine the best
is yet to be young man get after it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague rachel cruz and
we're taking you through this hour
taking your money calls your life calls
calls about your work and purpose
relationships and money the whole nine
yards triple eight eight two five five
five is the number to jump in triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you need to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question is from franzen from illinois
he says i'm i'm 32 years old with a bs
in computer science and psychology i
have been a software developer for the
last year and realized that recently
that i hate it i applied to a doctorate
program in clinical psychology and got
accepted i'm thrilled to have the
opportunity to pursue my dream career
but i'm terrified by the perspective of
debt to income ratio
i'm facing when i graduate i currently
have 31 000 my undergrad degree in
addition to the debt i'll take on for
the program i don't want to wait until
i'm 50 to start a life to start my life
because paying off debt
what should i do
all right brandon let's turn down the
drama queen knob just
yeah
you don't have to wait till you're 50.
yeah it's okay it's okay but
but listen brandon i mean you yeah you
should be terrified from the debt to
income ratio uh because you got 31 000
and if you go into debt
for a psychology degree and then you
have to get a master's in counseling we
just took a call similar to this in the
last segment i mean yeah you're you're
looking at could be a hundred grand
in the whole by the time you're all said
and done so so brandon if i were you
listen software developer yeah it's not
your dream job you hate it
but listen right now in this world that
can make some serious serious money
so if i were you if you even have to get
one or two other you know licenses or um
what are they called certificates
certification certifications in
that genre just to up your income just a
little bit more for maybe
two to three years it's not going to be
forever maybe until you're 35 and get
the debt cleaned up get some money saved
and then find a program that you can
work through to get your masters where
you can cash flow it
that's
that's the goal right because
yes while your dream is to
you know get a doctorate in clinical
psychology and to be able to do these
things
it can easily turn into a nightmare if
you're not making money in it because
it's a new
it's a new
career path for you and you have all of
this other debt
that you're in the hole for so you're
gonna have
way more control way more peace of mind
and wisdom comes into play for this yes
this feels good to jump in and just
pursue the dream
um and i want you to chime in on this
king because you talk about this all the
time but but there's a wise path to do
this where this setup doesn't become a
curse to you but it really becomes a
blessing yeah well i think you're right
about the drama queen stuff and i think
ultimately brandon has to realize that
this is a false narrative that you have
to go into debt to achieve the dream
it's just simply false
this is insane intensity but
if i was a 32 year old software
developer i'd be looking for as much
work as i could do contract work and
it's out there and developers make
really good money and yeah and i would
if you looked at 2500 a month
if you put 2500 a month
towards that debt
that's just over a year you're knocking
that out okay now that same intensity to
knock out the 31 000 undergrad debt
gets applied to cash flowing your way
through the doctorate program
congratulations on getting accepted good
news
you'll be accepted
and it'll be waiting on you and if they
won't wait on you someone else will take
you that's right and i can tell you this
i'd love for you to get real honest
about your why why are you going into
clinical psychology what's the doctorate
for
and i got to tell you a very unhelpful
unhealthy stressed out because of debt
clinician is not going to do as good a
work
as a debt-free
very healthy clinician is going to do
and
you're in the business helping people
get whole and healthy my goodness how
can you do that to the degree that you
were created to do it if you're slammed
stressed
over this so
you've created a false narrative you can
do it but i'm gonna tell you what it's
gonna take incredible intensity and some
patience
but
here's the good news both of those are
free
those don't cost you anything except for
serious commitment and conviction so hey
thank you for the question triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to modesto california john joins us
there john how can we help
hi ken hi rachel thanks for everything
you guys do i appreciate you guys well
we appreciate you what's up today
hey so um my wife and i we own a small
business and um we are halfway through
our baby step two
process currently on hold because we
have a baby coming uh at the end of this
year
third third kid first son so okay well
you know the good news is
is that i can speak to this and so can
rachel we both have three all right once
you go from two to three i gotta tell
you you've already got this thing down
so it's not gonna be that strong
i don't believe that i promise
no no two to three is harder but it's
the boy which is so fun that's what we
had john two girls
sweet okay
so but you're on baby oh pause baby step
two because pregnancy which is great
perfect piling up cash
the question is is um so
we have i've already paid off about 30
000
um we have about 30 more a little over
30 more um and when we pause
but um my wife has always been a little
concerned at how much i wanted to pay at
one time and then i
accidentally proved her right
because a couple months ago right before
we paused we came into about four
thousand dollars in vehicle repairs all
at the same time in a couple of vehicles
we have for the business
and so we actually ended up using up you
know the emergency fund plus of uh had
to take some cash flow out of the
business so my question is is how much
running a small business
while doing baby step two how much money
should i keep around
um and not just you know so that the
business isn't vulnerable while we're
trying to pay off this debt
yeah well i think john for you guys
separating the businesses over here
personal is over here
and so it really is looking right so in
a personal standpoint we talk about that
thousand dollar baby that thousand
dollar emergency fund and then
everything goes but when you're running
a business you got you got expensive do
you guys have employees do you have team
members
yeah yeah i mean yeah so i mean you guys
are are
are responsible for a lot on that end
right and running a business and so
um i think having two two to three
months
worth of savings in the business side
for business acceptance is specifically
is is a great plan to have because yeah
if you if you got no savings in that and
stuff starts happening in the business
you gotta
you gotta pull money from somewhere so
so having that safety net in the
business side is yeah is very very
important um how much do you guys make a
year
right now we're well we've been taking
home yeah right now we've been taking
home about 85. i plan on pulling that
back until after we're done with the
debt i want to pull it back a little bit
so that we can
accomplish some goals as far as growth
goes for the business yeah absolutely
take less personally but that's awesome
yeah right now while we're trying to pay
off that's what we're doing okay that's
great and so i mean you guys can knock
out the 30 grands you know rather rather
quickly make it 85. no question yeah i'd
like to have it done by summer time of
next year and then i'll call you guys
again yeah there you go absolutely i
love it yeah i like that well john you
got this thank you so much for the call
i i uh i love
i we've got this theme going on we've
got some young people that are just
they're they're just on the cusp of
total breakthrough
and they've got a plan john and his wife
they got a plan small business that's
the dream the baby coming in the baby
boy i mean
uh it's really exciting to hear that you
know and and i love how you you know
stipulated when you are a sole
proprietor or whatever and so your
business is your sole income you still
got to separate yes that's really
important and it gets confusing for a
lot of people yeah what's the big danger
there keeping it separate oh is that you
depend on that i mean that the i mean
it's kind of basic accounting when when
the finances start getting muddled yeah
you don't know what's going in what's
going on what side right so keeping it
very clean is very important yeah just
because you run it all doesn't mean that
uh it needs to be all one account and
all one philosophy so really good stuff
thank you so much for the call john all
right don't move
we'll be back before you know it this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman and i'm joined in studio by my
colleague rachel cruz and we are
thrilled to have you with us it is your
show america it is a conversation about
you your future your financial future
your professional future your
relationship future we're talking about
you
we want to give you hope for a brighter
future through clear steps forward
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple a eight two
five five two two five let's go to
columbus ohio next patricia is there
patricia how can we help
hey there thanks for taking my call guys
i appreciate what you do thank you
what's up i have a question so my mom
the grandkids were born she made it a
point to gift them a life insurance
policy and she paid for it the agreement
was she would pay for it for the first
18 years
and so she has purchased my for my
children a whole life fifty thousand
dollar policy um and she's been paying
on it for the past 18 years my son will
be 18 now so it's going to be our
our choice to either take it over
um it will be mature in 2023 so it's a
30-year policy we can either take it
over continue paying that premium
or there's a cash value to it which we
could cash that out
um
we got a late start we are on baby steps
567 currently um so we did but we did
get a late start on saving for my son's
college
so we're torn if we should cash this out
and invest it or continue paying for
this
um policy for him and he'll have a
fully mature 50 000 life insurance
policy and he may never have to you know
buy insurance um you know have a
pay a lot of money for insurance as an
adult
um so i'm just kind of torn in which
route to go
yeah it's a it's a great question the
short answer is cash it out today
whole life policies patricia are
terrible investments
and your son
while the the heart of your mom was so
good
and
so helpful
the vehicle at which
was probably sold to her is a just a
it's a terrible option because number
one kids don't need life insurance you
only need life insurance when someone is
dependent upon your income
and for children that is usually not the
case unless there's some child actor or
something making buku's money like
children don't need life insurance and
then they put it in a
an investment vehicle that makes on
average like three to four percent if
that
in return
versus as an example a good growth stock
mutual fund on average will be anywhere
from 10 to 12 percent
so there could have been three times the
amount of money sitting
in his account at 18 if she had cho if
they had chosen a different route so i'm
saying all that today i just want you to
see the math side
of why the purpose of having life
insurance is unnecessary for him and
the investment that's within that is
just horrible it's horrible
so i would 100 percent cash this out i
would take the cash and if you want to
use it for college i think that's a huge
gift that's that is tremendous
um or if there's a way for him to cash
flow school or there's other money and
he's able to take that investment and
and take it and open up a mutual fund or
something for him further in the future
then that's awesome too
um so those are two
options college or reinve or invest in
the market
um and then i'll say this as well that
there is a stigma that insurance is
expensive and i and i heard you say you
know it'll be expensive but term life
insurance for a healthy young person
once he starts a family once he gets
married
has kids and needs life insurance at
that point it is very inexpensive
actually it's not expensive at all a
term life policy um for for 20 30 years
and so he'll be able to still get life
insurance at a really inexpensive rate
while having an amazing
investment on the side through that
mutual fund or an investment in helm if
he chooses to use it for tuition for
college so does that make sense all of
that i know i throw a lot at you because
this is a really
there's a lot of layers to this um
idea and a lot of parents have this
right a whole life policy for their kids
and you hear it all the time uh we
actually have family members that this
happened to them they're like what do we
do it's 18 i'm like cash it out
um so that that's the reason behind that
patricia
okay and i figured as much it just is
you know i didn't want to make a
decision she's been paying on it for so
long and she's fine either way but yes
um so my next question i guess with the
investment you mentioned
more so mutual fund we would like for
him to be able to cash flow college not
sure that's going to be
you know 100
um yeah doable for him and like i said
we got a late start but should we just
put that into his 529 and let it go that
way or just have some more aggressive
mutual funds separately where he just
sits on it for a while yeah well if
you're going to be using it for tuition
i would just have it where it's liquid
where he can get to it so he can pay
semester by semester or year per year so
even if it just sits some of it um just
in a money market account and depending
on how how much is in the account if you
guys cash out today
it's not it's like thirty two thirty
three hundred dollars so he'll probably
use
yeah so he'll be using most of that just
for tuition so yeah don't i would not
invest it then if if he's gonna use it
for tuition put it in a money market
account and it's there for him to help
him through college
good all right thank you patricia
appreciate the call i mean you know
here's what happens this whole life
policy it gets sold as this really smart
thing and it's not very smart as you
laid it out with the numbers it is safe
in the sense that you know it's just
kind of like this little plods along
plaza long but it's essentially what you
put in it is what you get back you're
just not getting anything out of it yeah
and for everyone to remember your
investments
investments and insurance should never
be together ever so any product that is
selling insurance with investment it's a
bad product you want them separate
because again you can invest and make so
much more on your return
on again a very conservative mutual fund
like it doesn't have to be anything big
and fancy but you're gonna still get two
to three times the amount in that and
then you can buy insurance on the on the
other side really inexpensively
um and again the younger you are
obviously the less expensive insurances
the healthier you are the less expensive
it is
but yeah they're um they they force
those together and make a terrible
product that costs a lot of people and
what's hard too is i hear that i'm like
man i've heard that from so many people
and it's like the heart of the person
you know the grandmother was so good but
you're like man
he could have had she said what 3 200 i
mean he could have had 12 grand sitting
in there he had 32 000. oh 32 000 i'm
sorry yeah yeah so i mean but you're
right you talk about the compound
interest if you put that into 529 early
on
and it just grows it grows and grows oh
yeah i mean it's unbelievable because
the cost of college education right now
is skyrocketing i mean it is just
extraordinary um how quickly it's going
up and how expensive it is let's see
here do we have time let's go to lee in
houston texas lee how can we help
hey thanks for taking my calls guys hey
uh i uh
was wondering uh should i pay my house
off my mortgage off
uh my mortgage is my balance is around
300 000.
i'm 60 years old i'm retired
uh my wife's retired she just retired a
couple months ago she's 59
and uh so i'm thinking that's all the
debt we have
right now that's it um
we uh
we have uh both have ras
i worked uh
29 years well really 32 years for an oil
and gas
large oil and gas company and my wife
worked 33 years for
the government how much do you guys have
in retirement
um
as of yesterday 3 million 60 hey
way to go lee now
lee we only got about a minute 20
seconds i want rachel to be able to help
you on this do you have cash uh set
aside from from the retirement funds to
be able to pay the house off
no sir
no sir really cash we don't have much at
all we have less than twenty thousand
dollars in cash because you guys rolled
everything into van gaal okay and they
just handle everything for us okay yeah
and they send me about 5 000 a month and
my wife has a
60 000 pension okay okay
and she's 59 and you're how old
60. 60 okay because you guys quite are
not at the age just to cash out the iras
without a little bit of penalty
um if i'm correct i think it's yeah 62
16.
i
can you guys go back to work can you go
back to work and and you know work a job
and and you don't have to but can you to
be able to put to really
do that well there you go i've
yes i plan to go back to work uh but i'm
gonna do my i'm
i'm planning on getting an enclosed
trailer and
doing the handyman work all right well
listen you can do this don't touch that
retirement fund
don't touch it you're doing what you're
talking about the house house on the
side then once you're at the age you're
able to cash everything out you got
three and a half million i think you
said three million yeah you're gonna be
fine lee greatly congratulations
everyday millionaire hey i want to thank
rachel cruz our producer james childs
our associate producer jenna sears and
you america this is the ramsay show
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show and it's where america is hanging
out to have a conversation
about
your life i'm ken coleman joined by
rachel cruz we're here together today
to take your calls triple eight eight
two five
five two two five of course we're going
to take your money calls how about your
work are you gonna work that's just okay
or do you feel stuck you need a bigger
shovel to get out of the baby steps a
little bit faster and just move on up
do you long to do something that matters
to your work where you can make the
income you desire and the impact we'll
take those calls as well the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to san
antonio texas erica joins us there erica
how can we help
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call um okay so i am 25 years old and i
just got my realtor's license i haven't
worked since last year um like full time
or anything i graphic design and
illustrate on the side and that brings
in like maybe like 250 a month um if i
can get a commission but anyway i guess
i'm just wondering should i
should i just get like a part-time job i
don't want to focus all my time on
working at nine to five and i want to
build my real estate career
but i also need i mean i have bills and
i'm not making it oh my goodness no what
how
how far behind are you right now let's
just talk about the fact that you're
making 250 bucks a month that's it have
you been on unemployment insurance
i'm not on unemployment i receive child
support from my daughter and i get the
child tax credit that we're getting and
that's that's
how i've been kind of scraping together
for my for my bills and i was managing
part-time but that was that was giving
me like maybe 200 a week at the time
okay so this is this is not a simple
answer or a simple fix for you given
your realities here's what i know from
uh
from really good friends that are
successful realtors plus uh
you know i'm friends with one of the
leading real estate trainers
in the world
and at some point you're gonna have to
go all in on this right to make to make
the money that you want to make that you
need to make at some point you're gonna
have to go all in on real estate you you
can't do it part time and really max out
um exactly and you know that but we've
got this financial problem too so we've
got to stop the the the bleeding
and and then transition so the good news
congratulations you got your license um
what do you need to bring in
to not scrape by but to have some
stability what's the number oh my god um
a month
um
i want to say maybe
maybe
a thousand
at least all right let me help you let's
let's rachel are gonna help you rachel
help me out here so let's talk about
rent are you renting or do you have a
mortgage what's going on there
so i rent a room from from my mom and
i guess the house from my mom um so i
pay her 430 a month so 4 30 a month try
to but okay i've been behind
i have a car
currently i still owe three thousand
dollars on my car so i pay 170 a month
in my car
my car insurance is 200
um
and then i guess gas like monthly is
like maybe 60
okay and then you got food right
um i still actually have government
assistance for food government
assistance for food and how much are you
getting in child support
i make 500 in child support okay
in the thousand dollars that number
erica you said
is that
including the child support or is that
in addition to
um yeah no like everything's included
child support the child tax credit all
of that and then i guess yeah that's
like what eight hundred dollars so okay
three hundred something over 105 child
support right okay so yeah so so my big
thing for you right now is i just
it feels to me and i could be off
um
like you're probably not that it's a
little just out of control do you feel
that
you're there's no no structure there's
no structure okay and that's what i
think is the first step for you erica i
think you're 25 years old i think you're
smart
i think you have how old's your daughter
or son four four daughter my daughter's
four okay yes ma'am you got a
four-year-old um you're in and out of
this job you have a dream of a realtor
you're trying to pay you're getting
money in three different ways government
assistance with food i mean it just it
does feel it feels out of control so
i think my number one goal for you is to
get your income up
and ken can speak on this but he said it
one segment ago and that right now is
one of the the best times to get a job
in the history of our country so there
is going to be a job out there for you
it may not be realtor i kind of want you
to set that aside just for a little bit
um because again i want you to just be
stable i want you to have a stable job
something that you're making you know if
you can make
30 40 000 a year that will change your
life erica and i really believe there
are jobs out there that you can do this
you can find something again it may not
be the dream job it may not be the
passion but you are making an income and
what you're doing is you're adding
stability to your life
you're going to be moving out of your
mom's house paying rent living on your
own having dignity that you are doing
this and you are self-sufficient and you
can do this erica you can do this and
once you live that life
for a season and that can be whatever
you choose it to be
but to have that under you just to
breathe and actually have control over
what's going on to the point that you
can
i think is going to let your mind be
clear i feel like you may have jumped on
this realtor thing
because it felt like i could make a lot
of money and maybe i love people and and
this feels like a good thing and i'm
just going to try it is that kind of
what is that the motivation into it a
little bit
no so my uncle's a big realtor here in
this city and he he helps me with it he
helped me with school and everything but
i was last year i was at a nine to five
and i worked here for two years and i
i guess i
was a little spontaneous but there was a
drama in the workplace so i i left and
at that time i had been in an apartment
so i rocked up dead
in the apartment which is why i moved
back in with my mom and everything i
hear you okay so erica you ready for a
little pep talk
yeah absolutely okay listen listen
listen to me
your uncle's a big time real estate
guy in that area in san antonio and he
helped you get there right
okay now listen yes
is he is he for you does he want to help
you get started and win
yeah has he told you what you need to do
to win
he does is he gonna is he gonna help get
you a couple of deals early on is he in
that position to be able to do that or
is he just gonna mentor you you got to
go out and do it
well he's mentoring me okay now listen
to me so rachel's right so real estate
right now becomes part-time but what you
need to do is go out and get a job and i
want you to say no to the government
assistance pretty darn quick you're
getting the child support from from the
baby daddy and you got a good renting
situation with your mom's house that's
fine but you better go out and get
yourself a really good day job and
here's why
you've got to get stable get your budget
in order we're going to get you
connected to a free membership to ramsey
plus okay so we're gonna get you in
there so that you've got every dollar
you've got a clear path for financial
peace on how to get your house in order
but listen to me get a good paying day
job start saving up some money and
create a cushion for yourself to where
you can take three months and go all in
on real estate but that's six months a
year from now after you get everything
cleaned up but here's the other deal you
tell uncle uncle get me with a good
broker and i'm to sell and show as many
houses as i can on saturdays and sundays
and i'm not going to sleep you sell a
couple houses part-time it is possible
and that's going to fast forward this
whole deal but go get yourself a good
paying day job say no to the government
assistance you don't need it and it's
holding you back this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by rachel cruz and we're taking
your calls about your life your money
your work relationships
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five phone lines are open so uh
rachel there's a lot of hype as you know
in the real estate market my goodness i
mean it's hot hot hot buyers who think
they've now got to buy it's got to
happen right now because of how the
market is and a lot of that is because
mortgage interest rates have reached
some all-time lows and buyers are
frantic to lock in at the best rate
possible we're talking rates in the two
percent range which for reference three
percent was the gold standard for
decades
but
you're probably not going to get rates
any cheaper than that it doesn't give
you the green light to do stupid
so that means buying before you're debt
free or with zero down payment or
offering way over asking price and
waiving inspection those kind of moves
are high risk
and they're always going to cost you
more than you would save in the long run
so get your head out of the craziness
and look at your situation do you have a
down payment of 10 to 20 saved
can you afford homeownership do you want
the responsibility
if and only if your answer is a big fat
yes
to all of those questions
does it mean that buying a home is a
smart move for you right now so
uh it's easy to get caught up in this
hype that's when you need to get the
real facts
cold hard numbers staring in the face
before you get too serious about buying
or selling use our free mortgage
calculator there you can plug in your
numbers and see exactly what your home
ownership options are based on your
budget go to ramseysolutions.com and
click free tools that's
ramseysolutions.com and click free tools
and get the mortgage calculator that's
going to give you a whole lot of
information so you're not walking around
in the fog all right let's get to the
phones spokane washington is where mike
joins us mike how can we help
hey ken hey rachel how you guys doing
today great how are you
doing great loving that like always so
glad you just got to talk about real
estate soap because that's what my
question's about
so
um my wife and i are debt-free we have
our six-month emergency fund
and we actually have some money put
aside about 25 000 for
a down payment for our house here's
where it gets a little confusing for us
is she's going to school full-time and
not working i only make 40 grand
40 to 45 000 a year up here
and the real estate market is insane
and
with her
she is doing one more year community
college for cash flowing and then she'll
use my gi bill for the last two years
next year when she tries to do her
junior start her junior year
apparently it's a very competitive
program and she thinks that she may have
to take a gap year
if she doesn't get accepted and take one
or two classes which means she'd be
working full-time
and we'd be able to save up enough to
buy a house
my question is trying to figure out if
that's wise
with her not having a job yet and still
be in the middle school but also because
i once she gets her job in dental
hygiene after she's done with schooling
i will be quitting my job going back to
school
sometime between now and then
and going into youth ministry
quick question before rachel dives into
some of the numbers why are you going
back to school to go into youth ministry
do you have to have a degree to go into
youth ministry
yes and no um so i do
um you and me have actually talked about
this i actually called your show like
four weeks ago and you called me out oh
national on radio good was i right
because
yeah so i will be going into full-time
ministry um the churches around here
they're very
they want some actual education behind
the knowledge before
i have the passion in everything else
i've got experience
um but i just i need some
in-depth like
knowledge
that comes it wouldn't be a certain i'd
start off with a certificate which only
takes a year
um
okay i got it so we we talked about that
i don't want to go down the rabbit hole
but i i just that that's a money
equation so i've already told you i
guess what i needed to tell you so
that's good but
you know look
one little caveat on that
if the answer is yes and no then let's
focus on the no part let's run that
angle down and and a good church with
good if you've got good connections and
you've got a heart and you've got some
biblical education
i think you can do that so don't just
assume that that's what you guys got to
do okay uh on this money question so
should you buy a house is that that's
the that's the heart of the question
um so you're making 40.
she's gonna be going to school when she
gets out she's going to be
working you're going back to school so
how much will she make when she's all
done which i know will be in about three
years but what
roughly what will she be making
low ball in this area for a dental
hygienist is 65 to 70 grand okay
but that'll be in three years and
so what i would say to you mike is
people own a home on one income all the
time
um okay that is doable it is doable now
is it the wisest thing for you guys
right at this moment
um
i think owning a home is an amazing goal
and i think everyone home ownership is
something that i encourage everyone to
work towards because it's just a great
investment over the long time over the
long term
and i think owning real estate is
wonderful
and you guys are in a really great
position mike i mean you guys are out of
debt
you have six months of expenses in
addition to 25 000 save for a down
payment so you guys are in a position
that you could own a home i mean a home
at this point for you to obviously
depending on price is not going to be an
absolute curse but i would say you guys
are in a lot of transition a lot of
transition and it feels a little
unstable and the market is insane right
now like you said so there's no rush to
go in
and buy a home
so
if i i would be okay if you guys press
pause on the stream for about three
years until she has this job
and then you can quit yours go back to
school and do what you guys are doing so
so
it feel and it doesn't feel like you
want to buy a home from even your
questions is that right i
no no i
the reason why we started the dave the
financial peace stuff was because we
were about to buy at home and i went to
my pastor in tears
and because i was in the military time i
was a
six foot big guy in my going to my
pastor who's not exactly big and i'm
about to burst in tears because i was
terrified and he's like you need to go
to talk to these guys talk to this guy
and he let us the financial piece and
that's when we got out of
our debt we got everything figured out
so the main it's just and if she ends up
getting accepted this next year into the
school buying house won't happen because
she'll be in school last time it was
more of if she has to take a gap year
and is working full time and we make
more money we can put even more down on
a house
depending like what you guys said like
on the price but if we were able to get
down to where we put like 40
30 or 40 down and made it to where even
if when she went back to school i could
we could easily afford the more so yeah
might still be wise or yeah yeah as long
as it's 25 of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed rate you guys just got to
run the numbers and if it's within that
ball that that you then yes you're good
you guys have done the work you've set
yourself up to do it now again if you
press pause and just wait it a little
bit
you're in no rush i mean this is the
largest financial purchase you'll
probably make in your lifetime is a
house so we're not we don't want to rush
into it but you guys have set yourselves
up on a firm foundation to be able to
pull the trigger mike again if the
numbers work and it's and that payment
is no less than 25 of your take-home pay
in account to her going back to school
like run all those numbers out yeah mike
it's a simple math problem you answered
your own question uh but i think rachel
i think you're right here i
there's no if you buy it based on this
mic
it's a good decision right based on the
way we've talked it through but it's
also not a bad decision for you guys in
so much transition just to chill out and
keep saving money and rent for a while
there's just nothing wrong with that
you're not wasting your money or
throwing it into a wood chipper i think
a lot of people feel like
if i'm not buying a house and i'm not
getting equity and i'm not getting the
tax right off i'm throwing my money in a
wood chipper i might as well just be
burning my money and it's just not true
right i think you guys got to do what
you think feels the best emotionally
you're doing the right things on your
money you're walking the
the ramsey solution steps out but do
what feels right on this the houses will
be there you guys are in so much
transition but the best is yet to be for
you and uh congratulations on what you
guys have done so far proud of you you
guys are going to do great work all
right
don't move
more of your calls more of the ramsay
show coming right up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show america and we
are thrilled that you have joined us to
talk about you and your life your money
your purpose in your work
we're thrilled that you have joined us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two i'm ken coleman joined by
rachel cruz and we are taking your calls
so let's get to the phones idaho falls
idaho is where andrew is andrew how can
we help
hey guys i'm really glad you're running
the show today i
i have a question i'm actually sitting
in my car right now dressed with a
white shirt and tie i was about to take
my resume and reference this page into a
job okay
all right now andrew final decision
maker andrew i gotta ask this is
relevant is do they wear a white shirt
and tie in this place
they do it's a credit union all right
good because if they didn't i was gonna
tell you to take the tie off and
unbutton the shirt and roll it up roll
up the sleeve so good i'm glad you're
dressed the way they're dressed okay
keep going
king coleman's fashion segment has ended
well you got to dress like everybody
else you can't go in overdressed for a
job
that's right all right go ahead that's
right
so i as i was driving in as i was
driving in i got an email saying that i
wasn't selected for the position
and it wasn't that i was driving into an
interview i was driving in to try and
get ahead of the curve and introduce
myself to somebody
and it seems like
over the last several months i've
applied for dozens of places and
dozens of positions
and where i always fail
is at the hr level it's like i can't get
my
application to the interview process
yeah even when i tailor tailor my resume
and application specifically to the job
and employee qualified what can i do to
to get past that hr stage yeah it's
about your conditions it's about
connections
you can't even get an interview you're
not even in the interview process
on the dozens and dozens you're not even
really talking to a person right
uh-huh you know why because you're a
nameless faceless resume
connections my man relationships this is
how we get past the hr screening i just
shared an article about this rachel on
the ken coleman show last week they are
now estimating
that 10 million qualified candidates
a year are not even getting seen by
hiring managers because of the
artificial intelligence and the
technology that helps people gather
resumes faster right the days of walking
it off the street handling your resume
or over and so andrew i'm guessing this
is pretty consistent for you you're
submitting all these resumes online
correct
yeah yeah and i've been trying to i've
been trying to connect with the decision
makers on linkedin i've been trying to
nope trying to go in and talk face to
face with people
see that's all creepy now right i think
it's great right but i'm old school
rachel tell you i'm an old soul i'm like
an 80 year old 40-something guy but
here's the deal that doesn't work
anymore nobody wants to do that so
you're not link you're not listen
linkedin is good for information it's
not good for connection let me explain
you can find out valuable connections on
linkedin but then we got to pick up the
phone and talk to people all right i
wrote an entire book called the
proximity principle which takes care of
this and i'm going to give it to you at
the end of this call because it's really
about the art of connecting that's what
the whole thing is it says this in order
to do what andrew wants to do he's got
to be around people that are doing that
and in places where it is happening so
i'm going to break that down for you
really really fast all right andrew you
want to be working in a credit union
doing banking work i'm understanding
finance work
um what i want to do is i want to work
on financial literacy education is what
i want to do okay great so here's the
deal
who's working
on financial literacy education in idaho
falls idaho and you probably don't know
the answer to that right now but you can
find out the answer to that and then
when you find out the answer to that so
it's not just these companies it's going
who's who's the hiring manager over
there not the hr rep
i want to know who the hiring manager is
i want to know who it is and so what's
the name of this credit union that
you're that you're in the parking lot of
right now
it was called mountain america credit
union okay great how hard is it for you
to go online and figure out who the
decision maker is over there at that
place how hard is that
not too bad not too bad
so what i was about to do i was about to
walk in and talk to him well you can do
that but again they're going to look at
you like you got horns growing out of
your head here's the deal
i'm okay with you that you're there so
walk in and just go hey who's the hiring
manager what's the purchasing we'll see
how that goes but here's the deal you
can find that out online and let's say
we come up with a name i'm going to make
it up right now let's say that it is
sandra robinson all right and let's say
you go okay it's sanders sandra robinson
i got to get in front of sandra office
sandra is the one making the call how do
i get in front of sandra robinson here's
the deal i start going to everybody i
know close friends family members
acquaintances
social media relationships
and i'm going to say hey do you know
anybody works over there at such and
such xyz credit union
uh i don't but my uncle larry does his
wife works over there would you connect
me to your uncle larry and so we talked
to uncle larry and see this is just a
simple game of connections i've got to
find somebody who knows somebody over
there and here's how this works
so you make those connections before you
ever apply and then if they say yeah you
know what uh i'll vouch for you
i'll take your resume in so i'll apply
online with the artificial intelligence
right but i'm also going to have uncle
larry take it into his wife sue and
sue's the office manager over there and
sue walks into sandra and goes hey i've
heard great things about this young man
andrew do you understand that process
yeah yeah that would that's how we get
past hr
it's listen
your applause can call thank you very
much
well it's actually it's actually not
brilliant rachel but it is hey who do i
know it's true over there and if we go i
actually don't know anybody at xyz
credit union okay we don't take our toys
and go home and pout suck our thumb we
say who do i know that knows somebody
over there and at the end of the day
this is how we get past and this is how
people get hired at ramsey solutions by
the way yeah referrals we have tens and
tens and tens of thousands of people
apply every year at this place well i'm
just telling you if you don't know
somebody here
good luck you might as well go buy a
couple auto tickets right after you
submit your resume because the chances
are the same you've got to work
relationships and connections because
when somebody hears something good about
you here's what's happening this young
man has he said dozens and dozens of
resumes let me tell you what's happened
dozens and dozens of people have gotten
the job because they had some connection
some relationships some credibility they
got their resume so the whole like who
you know thing it actually it's true
it's true uh jenna let's give this young
man a copy of my number one best-selling
book the proximity principle now here's
what the book does
it's all about connections
all right the five people you need to
know and the five places you need to be
in to where opportunity comes up and
knocks on your door yeah the old days i
got to tell you first
okay
i've been in this job for 12 years so i
haven't
gone and applied to a lot of places but
i kind of still thought the old school
but it doesn't work like the idea though
of like yeah put your best foot forward
and you walk in there and you shake
their hands you do that now and somebody
goes please put a mask on
you know i mean like the days of going
to a receptionist and going hey who's
the manager here i know like they're
gonna look at you like why are you gonna
come in and do something yeah yeah come
on you know what i'm saying
no i a hundred percent i hate it it's
just funny that my idea is still like in
the 90s well here's the story
so one of my most inspiring stories when
i first started out i was 33 three kids
and i wanted to get a broadcast and i
read a story about katie couric
legendary nbc youtuber of the today show
yeah when she first got her start she
was she camped out outside of an office
building in manhattan
and there was an executive producer that
she wanted to get her real in front of
and she notoriously and famously camped
out and stalked the dude
and she got to him yeah and she and it
helped her yeah but
that's like
we can't roman it's a great story
i love it totally okay i love everything
about it
but that's romanticized and that's
really really hard we just can't do that
anymore and so
a lot of people here here's what i want
people to hear because a lot of people
listen to the show right now and you're
going ah i'm andrew i'm up to my
eyeballs ken i can't take it anymore if
i get one more no response because
people would rather hear know rachel
than crickets
but you submit all these resumes online
you don't hear anything you feel like a
loser yep folks listen to me you're not
but i'ma tell you something right now
you're submitting all these resumes and
you feel good about your activity you
might as well be spitting in the wind
it's just
a long shot your resume is getting lost
in a digital pile this isn't my opinion
these are the facts
10 million people in 20
20.
the resumes they were qualified they
never even were seen
get out there and meet people and say
hey will you connect me watch what
happens
it's not what you know it's who you know
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by rachel cruz as we take your
calls
today's scripture is colossians 3 2 set
your minds on things above not on
earthly things our quote today from gk
chesterton
one sees great things from the valley
only small things
from the peaks
good stuff there that's pretty deep you
have to think through that one for a
little bit
all right folks to the phones we go
triple eight eight two five five
two two five amy is joining us in
modesto california amy how can we help
hi rachel and ken thank you so much for
taking my call well great to talk to you
yeah
my husband and i
thank you my husband and i have always
been kind of on the davish side until we
were loaned a copy of the total money
makeover now we have the gazelle
intensity and the laser focus
we keep getting derailed um so my
husband's question more than mine
is we're on the fence about refinancing
our house
and including all our debt consolidating
our debt into that refinance to try to
chip away that a little bit quicker
okay so what debt do you guys have
besides the mortgage we have
besides the mortgage we have 22 000 on
the car loan
and 16 000 on a heloc
okay
and we only have about 100 000 left on
the mortgage okay awesome
okay so the only reason i don't like
the idea of consolidating with the
mortgage and honestly debt consolidation
in general
is that part of that gazelle intensity
is getting these wins
and when you have this big everest
mountain in front of you
it can it starts to it starts to chip
away at the emotional side of the
process and so there's something to be
said about hey we're going to knock out
the 16k we're going to knock out the 22k
uh we're going to save up and get an
emergency fund in place we're going to
do some other things before we go and
tackle the big mortgage
so i would not consolidate them all i
understand the idea of it because you
guys are are pumped and you're motivated
you're ready to get rid of everything
but i would not consolidate all of them
i would i would keep it still so
separate so the car
amy let's talk about that for a second
twenty two thousand uh how much do you
guys how much is it worth right now if
you were to kelly blue bucket
um
probably about
thirty okay
and how much do you guys make a year
we're at about 160 growth okay
awesome
so you got a good shovel for sure to to
be working on this and so you guys can
have i mean yeah i mean man amy if you
guys buckle down
and really really like you said you've
been davis you've kind of been just
messing around here or there
and i mean if you if you tighten up
everything i'm like you can you get all
this paid off in way less than a year
oh we're really
our goal is really two years for the
whole thing including the mortgage
including the money you keep getting
derailed rachel we keep getting derailed
with our air conditioner just broke yeah
that's why my husband wonders if it'd be
cheaper to do the consolidation if it
would save money
well in the long run mathematically i
don't know i haven't run the numbers i
don't know the interest rates all of
that but the idea is that is as you guys
are getting derailed not because the
that's not all together
it's because right yeah what what is
happening with your life and so what you
you guys again have
do you guys have a budget are you guys
working on like a on a zero-based
budget right now
my husband is a little more of a free
spirit that i we have a budget but i
have to say it's hard to stay on the bus
yes 100
okay yeah i'm feeling i'm feeling some
of this in the conversation and and the
idea amy is you know there's a little
bit of the reality that
if you keep doing what you've been doing
you're going to keep getting what you've
been getting and so there has to be a
level of change for you guys and i love
that you said at the beginning of the
call you know we're feeling gazelle
intense we read the book we're doing all
this but i want you guys to really clean
this stuff up because you can you have
an amazing income i mean you could get
rid of this debt so fast
if you guys tightened up cut your
lifestyle like you're not living
you know this
glamorous doing whatever you want i mean
you really are
tying up and cleaning this up because
it's going to be an amazing thing once
all this is paid off and you guys have
the cash flow to go and save up for an
emergency fund because i want you to
start you know press and play on
retirement again after that i mean
there's some stuff to do to chip away at
that mortgage and you guys can do that i
mean you have the income you just have
to have
the the restraints and the ability to
stay within a boundary which is the
budget and so you guys working together
yeah it could change it could change the
game yeah i mean the bottom line is is
hubs being a free spirit
and you not being able to stick to the
budget because of that is making the
hvac issues that bigger bigger of an
issue to where it derails you where it
shouldn't
and this just comes down to straight up
determination it gets down to going and
you don't want to sound like a nag and i
know you wouldn't be amy because you're
amazing but it gets down to going hey
i just looked at the numbers had we
stuck to the budget and this hvac thing
happened here's what the reality would
be versus what it is now because it does
feel frustrating when you feel like i
keep getting derailed well you're not
getting derailed yep
this is called life
and by the way rachel i've always found
in our life when we're saving up for
something that we want or we're excited
about something
something wrong goes it's just nuts yes
yes it happens it just happens and by
the way that's just the deal but it's
like it doesn't mean that you go well
we tried
it was a good plan it was good for a
while but hvac went
and the car went and then so we can't do
it you just can't have that mentality
yeah it's like do we want to get on the
other side of this or not it's the fight
it's the fight yep and amy and honestly
too i mean even selling the car i mean
twenty two thousand dollars
i thought you'd i was gonna say sell
that car i'd sell it right now yeah yeah
22 on it as i recall yeah and it's worth
30. yeah oh tonight yeah
here's why
right now not only is housing market hot
so is the used car market yes so i'd go
ahead and sell it now and you got eight
and i'm not kidding you when i tell you
i've been all over these used car
websites you can buy a very decent
little sedan yes for five thousand
dollars yes absolutely pocket three
absolutely put it on the debt yep
so yes i mean yeah i would sell the car
yeah and so it's going to take
these kind of decisions amy where you
just changed the way you've been viewing
it right you've been doing this and
climbing along and yeah this is a good
idea we're going to try it but kind of
sort of work some months we're on we're
kind of it is that ish sounding right
yeah and it's gotta be to the point that
you're like it's not working like what
you guys have been doing the reality is
and that's not to be mean to you amy but
it's just to say it's it's feeling fr it
feels frustrating the numbers are
frustrating all of it so to say we're
gonna just do something different we're
gonna just we're gonna give this a go
give this a go amy for 12 sell the car
give this a go
till summer 22 and if you hate your life
in summer at 22 because of everything
you've done
and you're like i want to get back in
debt and it's more fun not living on a
budget all that you're welcome to it's a
free country but i'm telling you when
you have this discipline and the wins
amy the wins that you guys are going to
start feeling because you've had a lot
of losses and i hear that in your tone
and in your voice it's defeating and
it's frustrating
but man once you start getting those
wins it's like oh okay this is possible
a hundred percent you know it's
interesting when we when we listen to
our debt-free screamers here on the show
it's always fun to ask them was there a
point in your journey
where you went from
the struggle and the gazelle intensity
that has to be there throughout
but that became kind of normal and you
were okay with it because you then
experienced momentum do you know what
i'm saying it's like you get to the
point where you go oh
we've had our heads down and we've been
busting it and living like no one else
going crazy rice and beans beans and
rice all the things
and now we go oh
we can see the light at the end of the
tunnel it's kind of like when you get
halfway through the race you know it's
like
the second wind is a real thing i heard
that term from runners because i hate
running as you know i have a deep deep
deep abiding hate for running and one
time dave ramsey goads me into the
national half marathon you know i did it
and i retired by the way as soon as i
finished i was one and done but here's
what i did learn in the training process
that you do get to a psychological
moment where you realize oh the hardest
part of the run is here i made it
through it i'm kind of starting to level
off and then oh i'm closer to the finish
of my run than i was to the start yeah
there's something magical that happens
and it really is that second wind
absolutely and in these baby steps
certainly baby step two the second wind
will come i don't know when it will come
for you but it will come but let me tell
you something you only get the second
win if you just keep putting one foot in
front of the other
every day
every week every month even if it's a
couple of years you gotta do it because
on the other side of this and math is
not gonna get you out of the problem oh
dating at all isn't so this second wind
it is it is work but like it's you're
not going to be able to map your way out
of this it's the truth rachel cruz
always fun my friend to be with you
thanks for hanging out with me hey uh
our producers james childs our associate
producer and call screener is jenna
sears and we want to thank you america
it is your show it is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you